"Wie heißen Sie?"
"Ich heiße ..."
"Wo wohnen Sie?"
"Ich wohnein der ..."
"Was ist das letzte, an das Sie sich erinnern können?"
"Also ich war bei ..."
"Ja, Herrschaftszeiten, Sie werden doch wohl einen geraden Satz rausbringen!"
"Ja, sag halt was! Was ist passiert?"
"Ja, es ist ..."
"Du bist ja ganz käsig. Geht's dir gut?"
"Mir geht's ..."
"... gut. Ja, das sehe ich. Wieso gehst du nicht ans Handy?"
"Ja, das liegt ..."
"... daheim auf der Kommode beim Aufladen. Ja, da liegt's gut."
"Wie heißen Sie denn?"
"Schwinghammer, angenehmn."
"Er!"
"Ich bin der Mann von meiner Frau."
"Wie ist Ihr Name?"
"Sibylle."
"Sein Name!"
"Keine Ahnung."
"Wie heißt Ihr Mann?"
"Schwinghammer!"
"Sein Vorname, Kruzifix!"
"Ja, das weiß doch ich nicht. Er sagt ja nie was."
"Haben Sie noch was zu sagen?"
"Nein."
"Er hat nichts zu sagen."
"Arme Sau."